donc ensemble aujourd'hui nous allons
comprendre comment travailler sur la
planète mars va nous permettre de
déchiffrer les archives perdu de la
terre alors pour ce faire je vais me
servir des instruments qui sont à bord
du robot curiosity ses nombreuses
caméras pour pouvoir vous emmener dans
ce voyage donc ce robot et sur mars
depuis 2000 12 mars est pas la porte à
côté
ces 400 millions de kilomètres ses neuf
mois de voyage
et pourtant au quotidien on communique
avec lui via les ondes
électromagnétiques en 15 minutes soit à
peu près la même temps qu'il me faut
pour faire une tedx conférence
donc comme vous le savez tous mars et
comme l'ensemble des planètes du système
solaire une vieille dame de plus de 4,5
milliards d'années mais elle est la
seule avec la terre à être dans la zone
habitable la zone habitable c'est à dire
qu'elle est à une distance du soleil qui
est telle que sa température en surface
autoriserait l'existence d'eau liquide
condition nécessaire à l'éclosion du
vivant et pourtant comme vous le savez
peut-être mars est un bloc tout desséché
gelé extrêmement désertique
elle a perdu l'eau liquide à sa surface
donc elle a perdu son bel équilibre
alors que la terre sur laquelle nous
vivons et dans la même zone et la
planète le bleu et qui a gardé ce
superbe équilibre mais pourtant la terre
n'est pas parfaite non plus car si on
s'amuse à raconter l'histoire de la
terre sur un livre qui ferait une
centaine de pages eh bien on est mal
parce qu'il nous manque les 10 premières
pages vous voyez la terre elle est née
comme toutes les planètes il ya 4,5
milliards d'années et de 4,5 à nos jours
les 5 premiers 1500 premiers millions
d'années eh ben on n'a pratiquement
aucune trace en a pratiquement perdu
toute trace des premiers continents qui
est qu'ils sont apparus sur la planète
terre et c'est bien embêtant parce que
c'est à cette époque là que la vie est
apparue sur terre donc il va falloir
trouver une astuce
il va falloir trouver une astuce est
pourquoi on n'a plus ses 500 premiers
millions d'années parce que sur terre il
ya un processus qui s'appelle la
tectonique des plaques et qui va
rajeunir le visage de la terre en
permanence donc elle va clift et elle va
perdre sa mémoire elle va être amnésique
et à la différence de ceux là et bien
sûr mars
y'a pas de tectonique des plaques donc
ce qu'on espère quand on va sur mars
c'est lire dans les archives de mars le
passé perdu de la terre à l'heure mars
où depuis une quarantaine d'années de
nombreux sonde se sont succédé et ont
permis d'établir déjà une carte
topographique alors sur ce planisphère
que vous voyez les couleurs chaudes
correspondent à des rôles de le relief
élevé au dessus de zéro jusqu'à 12000
mètres d'altitude les zones bleues
correspondent à des reliefs profond donc
en dessous de zéro jusqu'à moins 5 mm
que remarquez-vous tout l'hémisphère sud
de la planète mars
c'est un haut plateau extrêmement élevé
très plat cratérisée tout à fait lunaire
ce plateau est extrêmement d'anciens
voyez tous ces terrains que vous voyez
en jaune ils ont entre 4,5 et 3,7
milliards d'années donc c'est presque
60% de la surface de mars qui est
ancienne c'est tout ce qu'on n'a pas sur
terre vous voyez aussi qu'un équateur
extrêmement signaux voyez aussi à gauche
un bombement volcanique absolument
prodigieux d'où perce quatre boutons
blancs qui sont des volcans gigantesque
dont le moulin qui fait 20 kilomètres
d'altitude qui est le plus haut volcan
du système solaire et enfin vous avez
une plaine au nord qui est beaucoup plus
récente et qui est très profonde par
rapport à aux plateaux de l'hémisphère
sud
donc en fait 6 mars à toutes ces
caractéristiques donc ex exagération
verticale de ses reliefs alors qu'elle
est deux fois plus petite que la terre
tout y est deux fois plus grand tous les
terrains anciens sont extrêmement
développé c'est précisément parce qu'il
n'y a pas eu de tectonique des plaques
alors moment histoire géologique
mars peut se résumer à trois grandes
périodes le nom obtient l'espériez
amazonien c'est le maintien qui va nous
intéresser par ce qui correspond à cette
période très ancienne où la vie serait
peut-être apparus sur terre donc le
noachien canton à scruter les terrains
de l'hémisphère sud martien donc ces
hauts plateaux cratérisée on a vu des
stigmates absolument fabuleux que sont
des vallées fluviales dendritiques qui
prouve que l'on à cette époque a coulé
en abondance à la surface de mars
au point même qu'on pense que ces
rivières aurait nourri un océan dans la
partie boréale de l'hémisphère nord de
la planète mars
autre chose dans cet hémisphère sud sur
ses plateaux cratérisée on trouve plein
plein d'argile c'est quoi une argile
vous prenez un basalte que vous mettez
dans l'eau pendant des milliers d'années
et ben en fait il va se dissoudre il va
se transformer en argile qui est un
minéral gorgé d'eau donc on sens inverse
si vous trouvez des argiles à la surface
d'une planète c'est que l'eau a ruisselé
pendant des milliers des milliers
d'années et puis après donc on en
conclut donc que dans cette période
précoce mars primitive il ya un climat
tropical show des huches aussi humide
l'atmosphère était plutôt épaisse avec
plein de nuages comme sur terre et 3,7
milliards d'années catastrophe
climatique
qu'est ce qui se passe les grands
volcans se mettent en éruption
avec des ddd des émanations sulfuré
absolument toxiques
et puis le champ magnétique s'arrêtait
le champ magnétique d'une planète c'est
ce qui permet à la planète de maintenir
son atmosphère autour d'elle si le champ
magnétique disparaît l'atmosphère a
tendance à se volatiliser et à ce moment
là c'est le contraire de l'effet de
faire l'effet de serre qu'on est en
train de connaître actuellement la seule
inverse
donc il se met à faire à froid peu l'art
si j'ose dire et la pression
atmosphérique chute de telle sorte que
l'eau liquide n'existe plus la surface
de la planète
il existe de l'eau certes mais sous
forme de glace ou sous forme de gaz et
donc mars est devenu à partir de ce
moment là le frigidaire in
spitalier que l'on connaît donc en
résumé finalement mars mars donc
elle a perdu cet équilibre donc liées à
cette catastrophe climatique mais par
contre c'est une vieille non livre t
elle à la mémoire de ses origines ce qui
est exactement l inverse pour la terre
puisque la terre effectivement elle n'a
pas eu cette catastrophe
elle a permis que des êtres
unicellulaires avec l'évolution on
arrive aux hommes que nous sommes qui en
droit des robots sur mars mais par
contre elle a perdu la mémoire de ses
origines donc l'objectif des missions
martiennes c'est de se dire 6 mars a
connu l'émergence de la vie en même
temps que sur terre peut-on trouver des
traces de cette émergence dans les
terrains très ancien de la planète et
donc on va chercher des molécules
organiques notamment dans les feuillets
d'argile toutes les familles si on peut
être me de l'argile sur leur visage pour
enlever les points noirs les argiles
c'est des pompes à matériel organique
donc c'est dans les argiles qu'on va
chercher cette race donc deux conditions
il a fallu choisir un terrain
extrêmement siens donc dans l'hémisphère
sud de mars que voyez orangé et on a
choisi le cratère de gueule qu'un
cratère qui fait 150 km de diamètre
il est profond vous voyez se croise en
bleu mais surtout au milieu il ya une
montagne magique qu'on appelle le mont
sharp
c'est une montagne d'argile en feuillets
qui fait plus de 5000 mètres d'altitude
et là c'est le radeau de la mission
c'est l'endroit où on voulait tous aller
pour chercher ces molécules organiques
il fallait autre chose il fallait un
robot ultra sophistiqué dont classe est
au début de nuit la mission voyait
curiosity au loin le mont sharp avec le
cordon dunaire notre destination ultime
hénin on est dans une classe à j-2 alors
sur hbo c'est un robot incroyable il
fait près d'une tonne
il a six roues motrices il a un grand
bras de 45 kg et in amenas et vous voyez
en haut du mât un as their le laser
cannes sur lequel je travaille est un
laser français sur un robot américain
c'est la première fois il faut que vous
le sachiez
en foi ce type de laser dans l'espace
capable d'analyser les roches à distance
les roches le sol tout ce que vous
voulez alors à côté de cet instrument il
y en a neuf autres tous ceux tous aussi
sophistiqués les uns que les autres
notamment on a un autre instrument
franco-américain qui permet de mesurer
les cheminotes jeune homme sait quoi
carbone azote phosphore oxygène souffre
c'est tous les éléments traces à la base
du vivant donc cet autre instrument est
extrêmement important aussi
et puis on a 17 paires d'yeux 17 caméras
qui nous permettent de scruter
activement le sol de la planète mars
alors vous allez me dire quinze minutes
pour échanger mais on joue pas avec le
robot comme avec un joystick comment ça
se passe vous avez dix instruments vous
avez 50 chercheurs par instrument ça
fait cinq cents personnes qui tous les
jours se doit mettre doivent se mettre
d'accord pour les objectifs a fixé à ce
robot alors comment on fait même robot
il travaille toute la journée
et quand il va se coucher nous on se
réveille on reçoit toutes les données en
rafale on est en groupe thématique ou en
groupe instrumental on s'organise en
brigade c'est extrêmement militaire on
voit défiler ce curseur rouge on ne peut
pas être en retard
et là vous voyez c'est un jour où il ya
des les femmes françaises qui
travaillent sur le laser curiosity est
donc on se réunit et on va préparer la
journée du lendemain et en fin de nuit
pour nous les français parce qu'on doit
être coordonnée avec les américains eh
ben on va envoyer tout ce qu'on veut
faire faire aux robots dans la journée n
voire même plus un pardon donc en résumé
on atterrit au fond ce cratère au niveau
du point 1 et on a fait ce chemin
jusqu'aux points 4 là on est en ce
moment au pied du mont sharp 17 km en 5
ans vitesse de pointe cac 40 cm par
heure on va pas très vite et sur ce
chemin
donc on a rencontré d'abord tous les
éléments nous prouvant qu'il y avait une
rivière fossiles la rivière peace
valises après d'autres éléments nous
prouvons pour m'était tombé au fond d'un
lac asséché
enfin on a franchi un cordon dunaire et
on est au pied du mont sharp donc je
vais vous montrer
ces échantillons donc là ce sont des
coûts lamerat les conglomérats ce sont
des roches qui trace une rivière
fossiles vous êtes baigner l'été dans
des torrents vous voyez que le courant
du torrent va émoussés les cailloux qui
deviennent des galets et vous êtes aussi
chatouillé par des petites particules
d'argile donc maintenant imaginer que le
torrent s'achève pendant des milliers
d'années la roche qui va résulter de cet
assèchement c'est un conglomérat donc
une revanche avec un sim argileux et
plein de petits galets vous avez ce
genre de roche sur le terrain géologue t
rès extraterrestre vous savez qu'il ya
une rivière après on est allé dans ce
terrain c'était comme une petite cuvette
qui va tapissé de d'annahj argileux
absolument magnifique rougeâtre on a
fait nos premiers forages voyez large il
est oxydé en surface réduite en
profondeur et après on a fait plein de
l'inde analyses sophistiquées et dans un
de ces forages
on a trouvé voyez la petite molécule
hexagonal l'hexachlorobenzène qui prouve
qu'on avait en ce point là un substrat
de matières organiques à définir mais en
tout cas on avait un peu de carbone
après nous serons pardon je suis désolé
après nous sommes arrivés au niveau des
dunes à l'heure mais d'une sur mars est
extraordinaire ce sont des cordons
dunaires tout noir parce que sur mars
il n'y a pas de quartz y a pas de
carbonate qui donne la couleur jaune
donne aux dunes de sable sur terre en
fait les sables sont faits de petits
minéraux ferreux magnésiens comme le thé
rideau vert olive vert foncé donc les
bains d'une sont extrêmement sombre et
comme l'air et on n'est pas turbulent
mais subit d écoulement laminaire bas
vous avez cet espace de trappes est
absolument merveilleux et puis on a
franchi aussi des paysages de ce type on
se dirait au new mexico à santa fe là où
il ya des films de cow-boys vous voyez
ces douze pente argileuse surmonté par
des bandes kalt de craie extrêmement dur
donc ça c'est encore des paysages que
nous avons franchi enfin nous sommes
arrivés il ya quelques mois vous
et là sur ce petit cartoon voyez le
robot curiosity eh ben on est sur la
formation de murray au pied du mont
charles onians pied de ce colosse aux
pieds d'argile si j'ose dire de cet
empilement d'argile et on multiplie on
multiplie les forages pour chercher
chercher cette race de molécules
organiques
on en a trouvé une fois va-t-on
retrouver
il nous reste trois ans pour essayer de
voir si on trouvera ces molécules qui
serait peut-être des comment dirais-je
des éléments qui nous prouverait
peut-être que la vie est apparue sur
mars
alors quand on fait de la géologie sur
mars il me plaît souvent de rappeler
cette cette parole des premiers
cosmonautes qui revenaient de la lune et
qui disait on croyait découvrir la lune
on a découvert la terre et nous on croit
découvrir mars
mais ce qu'on espère c'est découvrir nos
origines l'origine du vivant sur terre
[Applaudissements]